اذا هذا هو مشهد الدمار الذي احدثه الهجوم
بالقذائف الصاروخيه على جامعه الاقتصاد
والتجاره هنا كما نشهد تقريبا الطبق
الثاني
للجامعه تقريبا تم تدميره
بالكامل وبحسب المعلومات التي حصلنا عليها
بانه اصبح تقريبا ايلا للسقوط وتتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه لمنع ذلك لكن هذا
التفجير لم يسفر الا عن هذه الخسائر
الماديه التي نشاهدها الان ولم يؤدي الى
سقوط ضحايا فقط تضرر المبنى والقسمه
الاداري لهذه المؤسسه التعليميه التي تعود
الى المرحله
السوفياء مرحله السوفياتيه ويبدو ان هذا
الاستهداف بحسب المسؤولين هنا تم عبر
قنابل عنقوديه وهناك حديث امني على انه
هناك صاروخا في هذه في هذا المكان لم
ينفجر لحد الساعه نور الدين دغير الجزيره